[Music]
good evening everyone my name is David
Bob I'm the director of the Kirby Center
Hillsdale College it's a great pleasure
to welcome you all this evening to
tonight's first principals on First
Fridays lecture by dr. Larry Arne 12th
president of Hillsdale College whether
you're with us here on Capitol Hill in
the Kirby Center Steve and Cindy Van
Andel lecture hall or watching via
webcast we are glad that you've joined
us tonight
one year ago Hillsdale formally opened
the doors of the Kirby Center some 40
years ago the college sent its first
student intern to the nation's capital
as part of the Washington Hillsdale
internship program 167 years ago
Hillsdale College began its existence
with a statement of gratitude grateful
to God for the inestimable blessings
resulting from the prevalence of civil
and religious liberty and intelligent
piety in the land and believing that the
diffusion of sound learning is essential
to the perpetuity of those blessings the
founders of the college stated that the
Hillsdale would be committed to best
develop the minds and improve the hearts
of the students Hillsdale College
operates today with this end firmly in
mind so that we as citizens young and
old alike might live worthy of those in
estimable blessings in formulating the
college's mission Hill sales founders
drew deeply upon the wisdom of America's
founders and it does that wisdom tonight
which dr. Arnn will address as his topic
his forthcoming book has a short title
and a long subtitle the founders key the
divine and natural connection between
the Declaration and the Constitution and
what we risk by losing it it promises
what it for its readers what his
students at the college receive in class
a careful consideration of what it means
to be a human being what it means to be
a citizen and what is stake what is at
stake today for our nation to introduce
dr. Arnn this evening I now ask to come
forward Hillsdale College senior and
politics major Nicholas young strim this
semester he's as part of the Washington
Hillsdale internship program interning
in the office of House Speaker John
Boehner Nick
[Applause]
hello everyone dr. Larry P Arnn became
the 12th president of Hillsdale College
in 2000 he received his bachelor's at
Arkansas State University and his
master's and PhD in government from the
Claremont Graduate School from 1985 to
2000 he he was served as president of
the Claremont Institute he is the author
of Liberty and learning the evolution of
America's education and the founders key
which is the topic of today's speech
please join me in welcoming dr. Larry
our
[Applause]
Thank You Nick
thank you David thank you all for being
here we're here in Washington DC which
as you know is the center and creator of
everything in the universe and so I
thought I should direct our attention
elsewhere first of all the chairman of
our board is here and he's about the
greatest guy that ever was and his name
is William J brought back and he's right
there and the second thing is sad we're
here in the Steve and Cindy Van Andel
lecture hall dedicate a year ago and
Cindy Van Andel was I am sorry to say
one of the most beautiful 57 year-old
woman I ever saw in my life you can look
at the picture back there it's recent
she's a gorgeous person she's kind and
caring and sweet and everyone testifies
to her goodness and she died four days
ago and her husband Steve
she's a 1975 graduate of Hillsdale
College her husband Steven ándale who's
chairman of Vania van wey and was the
president of the United States Chamber
of Commerce he's a member of our board
is a member of our Executive Committee
is a wonderful man
and we send him our condolences she died
of cancer and six weeks notice and we
grieve for that very much to prove that
Washington DC is not the center nor the
maker of the known universe I can tell
you that the most important thing that's
happening in the country tonight is
happening in San Bernardino California
because they're the Hillsdale College
charger ladies volleyball team is in the
semi-finals for the national
championship
[Applause]
at 10:30 Eastern Time 7:30 Pacific time
you can go to the NC double-a website
and navigate to the women's volleyball
page and you'll find a link there and
you can watch the match for free and you
will marvel I mean a Cal State San
Bernardino is the undefeated number one
ranked team in the country and they're
the hosts of the tournament and that's
who we're playing tonight to see who
gets to the final and they look really
fearsome to me but our girls will look
both beautiful and fearsome to you I
think and I'll tell you something odd
about those girls so I can brag on them
a little bit they're all students these
girls and the guarantee of that is that
radical thing that we do at Hillsdale
College about half our curriculum a
little more than half is made up in the
core curriculum and that is the study of
the great books and the natural sciences
and the languages and it's very
difficult and everybody has to take it
and it doesn't make any difference who
you are and that means come to Hillsdale
College you got to be a student
so those lovely powerful girls that
you'll watch on the thing if you go look
and there'll be a lot more entertaining
than I will be tonight they're very
smart and if they weren't they'd flunk
out so go girls do great and I'm not
finished to writing Washington yet
there's still one more thing I have to
say there's something you're forbidden
to do in Washington now and nobody knows
how we became forbidden to do it it just
happened there was a time when everybody
did it long about this time of year and
then you couldn't do it anymore and if
you do it it's kind of crass it's not
quite right to do it
you can surmise that I'm about to do it
whatever that thing is
but I want to call attention to the fact
before I do it that I'm not supposed to
do it and that will lead me into what I
want to say to you tonight I can tell
you the reason why I'm going to do it
there are three reasons and they are the
three purposes of Hillsdale College come
to find out the college was founded in
1844 as d-bob said sorry dr. David Bob
the director of the one of the vice
presidents at the college is named
Richard Pei Wei he's big tall long thin
guy so I call him mr. pee-wee so Dee Bob
said that we have this mission at
Hillsdale College written before the
Civil War it's very beautiful and one of
my points is going to be that beautiful
things are the most important things
there are they matter more than anything
else and they are also the most
commanding and compelling things there
are and I'm going to argue that it is
the deprivation of the beautiful things
that is the cause of the despotism that
is surely coming upon us except that
we're going to stop it because of the
power of beautiful things and our
college was founded in service of these
beautiful things and all of the marvels
that it's worked in its hundred seventy
years including the marvel of this
building a recent marvel including the
marvel of that painting a recent marvel
including every lovely thing you see
around us was called forth by these
beautiful things and the College was
built upon precisely three of them and
they are contained in one sentence the
opening sentences the college's founding
document as I say it's a beautiful
document people have died for the
meaning of that document people from our
College they risked their lives for the
meaning of that document two of them
were chosen to bear Lincoln's body from
the Springfield railway station to his
grave because they had risk mortal
injury at Gettysburg
and won the Congressional Medal of Honor
there in the name of the principles of
that document and the principles as I
say are just three and they are by the
way just like the principles of our
country the first principle is that we
stand up for what we call civil and
religious freedom that's stated in the
first
and that that that good I can tell you
is America's gift to the world first
realized here actually as George Bush
said better than I once it's not
America's gift to the world it's God's
gift to man we love freedom at Hillsdale
College including the religious kind and
for that reason we've always been open
to everyone this room and this broadcast
is always open to everyone of any faith
if they're a person of good will and you
will get a Christmas card from us and
it's called that and it contains a quote
from George Washington on it every year
and the quote is from the first letter
that a chief executive of any country
ever wrote to some Jews greeting them as
equal citizens outside Israel that is it
is now no more he says that we speak of
religious toleration as if it were by
the indulgence of some that others enjoy
their inherent natural rights that's the
first purpose of our College it's the
reason we stand up for freedom it's the
reason that we've always believed that
you can't take account of anybody's
color when you do things like admit them
to college because skin color is not a
qualification to think and we've always
done that always fought for that some of
those people who died for the Union Army
in the Civil War had heard Fred Douglas
give a speech on our campus if you look
at a book of photographs of Fred
Douglass one of the most famous of them
any good book was is a photograph that
was taken in central hall which still
stands on our campus that's the first
the second it says the articles is that
we stand for intelligent piety that
means we don't like impiety and we don't
like dumb piety God is the kind of being
that would be really good to know
something about and if you study hard
enough you can figure out some things
about it in fact some of the greatest
proofs for the existence of God are
rational alone and those proofs tended
to strengthen faith and our College it
says in these same articles that begins
with the devotion to civil and religious
freedom and intelligent piety that the
teaching of the Christian faith by
precept and exam
well shall remain a conspicuous name of
our college and it is that today and it
shall be that tomorrow and the third
thing about the college that you need to
know is that it says that sound learning
is necessary to the preservation of
these blessings of civil and religious
freedom and intelligent piety and what
is sound learning it names what it is
it's learning that is literary
scientific and theological in its
divisions and it's learning that
improves the hearts and develops the
minds of the students in other words it
produces through its operation the moral
and the intellectual virtues now I'm
going to claim after I do this thing
that I'm not supposed to do that it is
actually the loss of that kind of
learning that is responsible for the
impending death of freedom in our
country and that to get that back is the
only thing that can call us back to the
preservation of that freedom Merry
Christmas
[Applause]
Christmas brings up the eternal and the
urgent it is about the contact of God
with earth one of the two contacts in
the Christian faith and it is this
connection and difference between the
eternal and the urgent that is at issue
today in American politics it's easy to
say and it's true if you had to name
what made the United States of America
if you reasoned about it for a few
minutes you'd have to come up any list
of five would have to include two things
and one is the Dec Royce of Independence
and the other is the Constitution the
United States and those two things are
different in their nature because have
you ever thought about the difference
between them the difference is obvious
on its face this book that I've written
by the way you won't I don't know I
think I'm not supposed to say that you
won't need to read it if you listen
carefully tonight on behalf of my
publisher I said you must still read the
book on pain of strapping I said there's
a connection between them but the
connection is not obvious and it's very
commonly divine didn't deny it because
first of all have you ever noticed the
Declaration of Independence is very
beautifully written and the Constitution
United States is not do you ever read of
it you ever think about that when you
read them I mean the preamble to the
Constitution is pretty good but there
isn't anything quite like the claim that
there are laws of nature and of nature's
God that these entitle us to rights that
are fundamental and apply to every one
of us whenever and wherever we are born
that's a very remarkable thing to happen
and it speaks exactly and precisely and
repeatedly in the name of eternity and
it's in a very urgent situation that it
does this but that's what it does it's
it's incredible the scope and breadth of
the thing and that's not as incredible
as the height of the thing never been
anything in politics done quite like
that of course it's a very dramatic
thing to have done because it ends with
this death pledge if the beginning is
Universal and grand and elevated all the
way up to heaven the end of it is in
that room you know maybe a time and a
half as get a big as this room where 55
or so people are gathered and where they
mutually pledge to each other their
lives their fortunes and their sacred
honor
I have to interrupt myself and say that
I just saw walk in here one of my
students who has recently graduated from
Yale Law School and he's come here
tonight to remind him what the
Constitution United States means a
Morell see the Alumni Association will
be all over him there from from Yale so
that's the declaration right and what
happens in the Constitution what happens
in the Constitution is there's all these
details there are seven articles you
know the Senators will be this age and
serve this long and represented this way
and on and on and on it goes right and
there's bills of attainder and coining
money and all that stuff and it's not
glorious it isn't when in the course of
human events it becomes necessary for
one people to dissolve the political
bands that have connected them with
another and to assume among the powers
of the earth the separate and equal
station to which the laws of nature and
of nature's God entitle them is that not
complete and dispositive and eternal
and by the way it's because the
Constitution differs from the language
of the Declaration that an opportunity
has been found an opportunity to sever
them to divide the one from the other I
have a quote that I like that explains
how it does this is from Joseph Ellis
historian do you guys know who that is
he's good he's a very good guy thank
must be a wonderful man I don't know him
but this piece of writing here I'm about
to read to you is indefensible here's
what he writes he follows by the way
most historians and writing this there
were really two founding moments the
first in 1776 which declared American
independence and the second in 1787 88
which declared American nationhood by
the way I'm not going to talk about it
but that sentence by itself doesn't work
the decorative independence is the
seminal document in the first instance
the Constitution in the second the
former the Declaration is a radical
document that locates sovereignty in the
individual and depicts government as an
alien force making rebellion against it
a natural act now I swear that this
fella is a teacher in a major university
a college actually the latter the
Constitution is a conservative document
that locates sovereignty and that
collective called the people makes
government and essential protector of
Liberty rather than its enemy and values
social balance over personal liberation
now the consequence of that kind of talk
by the way because if it's really true
that there were two foundings and one is
about the eternal rights of man and the
other is about the specific structure
and manner in which we will be governed
and they're not connected
what follows automatically it means we
can organize our government in the old
way we want to the Speaker of the House
two years ago was asked by a journalist
you can hear a recording of the
interview on the internet now the
journalist was from CNN I'll send you
the reference if you ask me where in the
Constitution do you get the authority to
require person to buy health care and
the response was quote are you serious
are you serious now by the way on the
Sunday afternoon when they passed the
whatever that dang thing is called
Patient Protection and Affordable
something something the Obama care bill
Nancy Pelosi read with great respect
from the Declaration of Independence she
got that wrong too but she admires that
thing right she gets to make it a mean
whatever she wants it to mean but the
Constitution did by the way to which she
personally swore an oath as a condition
of holding office is an afterthought or
a negation and that's made possible by
the fact that there were two founding
moments the one a radical document that
locates sovereignty in the individual
and depicts government as an alien force
now the declaration independence is a
little less than 1500 words long and it
is divided into three sections in the
first section is a proclamation of some
universal principles and the second
section is some charges against the king
and those are very important I'm going
to talk about those a few for a few
minutes and the third section is about
implementing the thing that is to say we
hereby declare that this thing means
this thing all this stuff we said before
and we are prepared to die for it
that's the end universal particular
particular that's the structure of the
Declaration about 1500 words long that's
about twice
as long is an op-ed article in The Wall
Street Journal in other words it's not a
great feat of scholarship to master its
words anybody who hadn't read it could
do it tonight before they go sleep
the former document is a radical
document that locates sovereignty in the
individual and depicts government is an
alien force making rebellion against it
a natural act I can't find it the first
charge against the king in the list of
17 he has refused his assent to laws the
most wholesome and necessary for the
public good I think what it means that
Thomas Jefferson enlisting the reasons
that justify the rebellion picks that is
the first one in other words we are not
rebelling because government is an alien
force we are rebelling because it has
not been provided to us in other words
exactly opposite the point and explicit
and hidden they're buried in a vast
document of fewer than 1500 words now
it's not just that one accidental thing
it's over and over it says it what is
the first right that is proclaimed in
the back course of Independence I just
recited it when in the course of human
events it becomes necessary for one
people to dissolve the political bands
that have connected them with another
for one people people that's in the
plural right it's not an individual
right it's the right of a people and to
assume among the powers of the earth the
separate and equal station to which the
laws of nature a people is entitled to
form and provide government for itself
and so that means by the way that it's
obvious and it's profoundly true in
every line because there's no line in
the debt course of Independence that one
can read to interpret it to say
government is an alien force the exact
price of Independence is interested in
government and it's interested therefore
necessarily in how the government should
be arranged and come to find out that's
important and I'll tell you why it's
important because we've gotten ourselves
into the most remarkable mess these days
are you we're Merry Christmas
it
the nature of the mass goes this away
the part of the Constitution that we
celebrate the most is article 1 section
8 in article 1 section 8 lists the
things that the Congress can do and so
to return to the Constitution is to
return to those things but to return to
those things is impossible at least in
the short or intermediate term and the
reason is education is not among those
things and healthcare is not among those
things and retirement benefits is not
among those things and welfare is not
among those things right and that by the
way I just named most of the government
of the United States and we have made
enormous investments in those things and
we can't really lose the investments I
mean you know we it is true they have
very significant net deficits those
things but there's been a lot of assets
put into them too and so the American
people are not going to vote and ought
not to vote by the way to simply
dissolve all those things overnight and
that means if you're a constitutionalist
how you gonna go about being that I
don't know well actually I tell you I do
and in a minute you will because I
thought about that for a long time and I
thought there needs to be something we
can do
that sets us on the road back to where
we need to be and since we're not gonna
abolish Medicare you know the the Paul
Ryan plan which you know I adore that
guy I and ice you know it's not my
business to support or not support the
Paul Ryan plan I haven't read the dang
thing although you know I know its main
outlines but if you know its main
outlines you know it's not justified by
article 1 section 8 of the Constitution
so what are you gonna do if that comes
up for vote you're gonna vote for it or
not and I guess if I were in the
Congress I would so what can you do is
there something about the Constitution
that has a dignity today
that we could support today and come to
find out there's a constitutional
understanding written in this middle
section of the Declaration of
Independence and it specifically
emphasizes the main features of the
Constitution as it was later written so
the Declaration of Independence is
interested in government and it explains
how it ought to be set up in that
something did you ever hear that before
me neither so now I've lost my specs and
I've lost my place but I'll get straight
now
I'm going to name three things that are
constitutional in the Declaration of
Independence that seemed to me according
to it necessary to free government and
by the way notice the character of these
things because the way the debt crisis
of Independence is written it begins by
an assertion that we humans in our
equality that means above the beasts and
below the divine that we humans have a
natural authority to organize government
according to the way we want and then it
goes and says we're right to do this in
these circumstances because the king has
done these things and it doesn't say it
doesn't say he did them after he agreed
not to do them it's just the fact that
he did them that makes them wrong
anytime such things are done they are
invasive of the rights of man and that
list is very pregnant with meaning for
the shape of a constitution if he just
read that read it and here's what one of
them is he has erected a multitude of
new offices and sent hither swarms of
officers to harass our people and eat
out their substance it's not the only
one that's a famous one right don't you
like that one by the way thank God
nothing like that's going on today
because because we'd be in a world of
hurt if something like that was
happening now in fact by the way the
richest Society in the history of man by
a lot teeters on insolvency and what
were they worried about back then what
had been going on right why did the king
do that the story of the revolution is
replete with the reason the point is in
1763 the British won a back and big war
and they became the great world power
and they decided we're gonna run these
colonies they've been costing us a lot
we're gonna we're gonna govern these
things and so they started telling them
what they were
I have to do and by the way they started
passing laws that Kings had been
beheaded for trying to pass in British
history to apply to the to the Americans
and the Americans said wait you can't do
this and so the king did what they do he
passed a bunch of taxes and he used it
to hire a bunch of people to force them
right and so now the government is going
to overwhelm the society and do you
think that didn't make them angry he is
kept among us in times of peace standing
armies without the consent of our
legislatures he is affected to render
the military independent of and superior
to the civil power he has combined with
others to subject us to a jurisdiction
foreign to our Constitution by the way
the claim is made by Thomas Jefferson
that the colonies already have a
constitution and they have one
unacknowledged by our laws giving his
assent to their acts for quartering
large bodies of troops among us so in
Boston Harbor this big sailing ships
come in and what gets off them except
soldiers with bayonets clanking and a
rip that says that we get to stay in the
barracks of your militia and if that
won't hold us we get to say in your
public houses and if that won't hold us
we get to stay in your homes so you see
the government is to overwhelm the
private society and I want you to
understand I'm gonna make a lot of that
fact this is to be the first great
liberal society in all of history the
first great free society and the first
condition of that is that the free
society be large and the government be
small now across the street at the
Heritage Foundation they keep these
numbers better than I can keep them and
when they tell me what they're I can't
remember them so forgive me if I get
them wrong but I don't think I will
I think the gross domestic product of
the United States is about 15 trillion
dollars Matt Spaulding's there he's
laughing if I get this wrong but Matt
Matt's not the kind of guy we'll know
either I think it's about 15 trillion
dollars and I think that state federal
and local spending is close to seven
trillion and if I'm not mistaken half of
fifteen trillion is seven and a half and
Obamacare is coming and is that not said
to be twelve percent of the GDP or
something like that can you see that
it's possible that the government might
be about to become larger in economic
terms than the private society and by
the way that's not constitutionalism
because how's the constitution itself
written except that the powers that are
not delegated are held by the people and
they have only given certain ones and
that's the whole structure of the
Constitution but I'm saying that a
breach of that fact is one of the causes
of the American Revolution we should
have a liberal society and that means a
large and thriving and vibrant private
sector for example liberal arts colleges
you know ours was started in 1844 and
that makes it you know about two-thirds
of the way back in age it means a lot of
them were started before and you know
they made it on their own until about
1965 and thought they were doing a great
service cuz you know I'm saying we had
about a hundred boys at the Battle of
Gettysburg and when Joshua Reynolds said
to his adjutant we're gonna run down
that road and we're gonna get there in
time and two-thirds of them were dead by
nightfall it means a hundred students
from a little bitty liberal arts college
that nobody had ever taught anything
military to they just taught them to
love freedom like today
we do that they were in that bunch and
they ran down that road and most of them
died
now the government didn't pay any money
to get that to happen but it was right
that it didn't because the government
actually belongs to the people it is our
responsibility it is not some large
thing from which we take it is there to
be there for us and so the first precept
of constitutional rule is that we should
have a limited government and for
goodness sake couldn't we agree that the
government ought not to be larger than
the rest of the society and if a person
couldn't agree to that then he would
have to admit that he is not in favor of
Liberal government but the declaration
independence says that we have a right
to that and it says that if we are that
is deprived if we are deprived of that
it says that we declare to such people
who attempt to do that our independence
and we will hold them in peace friends
and in war enemies once you have a
liberal society to additional Marvel's
become possible they're the most awesome
thing and they never happened anywhere
in human history until they happened
here not either one of them the first
one is if it's true that there's this
big society and they can own the
government then something becomes
possible that's not possible otherwise
and that is the authority over
government can be outside government you
see sovereignty James Madison says that
first time in history sovereignty is to
say the legitimate title to rule is
entirely located outside the government
and then government can be and this is
my second point the first is limited
with sovereignty outside the second one
is the government can be representative
and that has some big benefits that are
simply huge and the main ones are to
the first one is in the government and
remember it's the position of the
Declaration of Independence that the
government needs to be powerful big
enough to win Wars big enough to protect
us from Osama bin Laden by killing that
man which is what he needed you know
he's a much better fella than he used to
be but if the power to control it is
outside then everybody working in that
powerful thing can work for someone
outside that's the first benefit but the
second one is they say in Sunday school
is like unto it and that is I'm gonna
close by saying why you have to have all
these arrangements according to the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution but a little portent is
just simple if there's a problem with
the government being too powerful that's
because the government is constituted by
people but we're people too so that
means we shouldn't be too powerful
either and if we are sovereign but we're
in an entirely representative system we
can't do anything today except argue and
grump and carry on like I'm doing right
now but that's good for us because it
means that we get used to thinking
before we act because we have to wait
for election time you know two months
ago we might have elected Herman Cain
president probably not now and I'm you
know I don't mean to criticize him he
was just on the campus I'm just saying
people got a minute to think about it
and facts were revealed or maybe they
were I don't really know and and and so
we can chew on that we can think before
we act and that's good for us but by the
way think what it means about the
liberal society because if you set
things up that way as Madison says that
was done for the first time in history
in the United States of America
it does mean that the only way the
the sovereign can control the government
is through elections
whereas in Athens the people would meet
and cast a vote or in England the king
was sovereign and he would be the
executive branch in our case the only
way we can do it is we wait for
elections but by the way what's going on
with elections the government's very big
now isn't it and its retainers are very
big players in elections another reason
why you need a liberal society because
you could see how if the elections are
dominated by people inside the
government or was interest connected to
the government sovereignty could move
inside the government so you see that's
a fundamental constitutional arrangement
and it is threatened by the growth of
government it's a purely representative
form made possible by a liberal society
where the government is not so big that
it can send swarms of officials to eat
out our substance and harass our people
but by the way the third thing is simple
and that is once it's a representative
form then it can delegate the authority
of the people to different places and
what becomes possible because of that
separation of powers and you know about
both representation and separation of
powers neither the Declaration of
Independence nor the Constitution can
shut up for a minute
many of the offences that the king has
worked are interfering with
representative assemblies and he even
even accused him of this he says okay I
won't let any law be passed to take care
of this problem you've got unless you
give up the right to representation and
he said and there in Jefferson writes of
that formidable only to tyrants and he
also writes of it incapable of
annihilation it must go back to the
people if there's no law to doubt to set
up representation they take up to put
the power to govern directly then and so
if you have representation
you can have separation of powers now
did you ever count the clauses of the
Constitution and think what they're
about there are seven one of them is
about how you ratify the Constitution
one of them is about how you amend the
Constitution and one of them is about
the transition from the Constitution to
the articles from the Articles of
Confederation to the Constitution and
that leaves four that are about the
regular operations of the government now
in the Declaration they're very critical
of the king because he keeps interfering
with judges for example that's the worst
offense the worst single thing that the
government can do is get between a judge
and a citizen because you see what that
protection is and how sacred that is if
the if the Congress passes the law but
it can't execute it it takes somebody
elected by some other means to execute
it if that happens that's protection but
then if the person in the executive
branch reaches out his hand and grabs
you and says I'm gonna put you in the
pokey and take your property you need a
judge and he needs to be serving for
life and he needs to be just the kind of
guy who will say to the executive stick
it and you know in England where my wife
comes from and to whom the Declaration
of Independence is addressed what's all
that about right
they forgot the lessons they learned
Charles the second was Charles the first
was dead not around to remind them
so you see separation of powers of the
four that are left article one is about
the legislature Article two is about the
executive branch article three is about
the judges an article four is mainly
about the states and by the way those
are the four places to which the
government of the United the people the
sovereign people of America delegate
their governing authorities now you may
think well that still works right
of course the states but it doesn't
because you know what's happened that
changes both the representative
character of the government and
separation of powers do you ever hear
the fourth branch of government does a
guy who teaches at Harvard Law School
Klarman is his name and you know Robert
Byrd got through a law that says that if
you take money from the federal
government near a college you have to
have an annual Constitution Day
celebration so all the colleges have now
and so they all invite speakers to come
and tell the students how bad the
Constitution is and Mark Michael Klarman
gave such a thing in 2010 I think it was
and he says the Constitution is very
evil we can't follow what he gives for
reasons but then one of the reasons he
says is that the Constitution doesn't
allow for this new fourth branch of
government the administrative state in
other words the bureaucracy and what's
the point about these bureaucracies by
the way why are they favored why are
they the darling of modern liberalism
they don't represent anybody and they
hold all three of the powers of
government in their own hands if Boeing
doesn't like the National Labor
Relations Board telling it that it can't
make Dreamliner's in South Carolina
first of all Obama he's quoted in the
paper well I can't do anything about it
it's a regulatory agency he appointed
you know a majority on the board and
doubtless they're doing what he wants
but he can't really make them nor can
anybody but if Boeing wants to protest
about it they have to do by the way
exactly what Hillsdale College had to do
when it didn't like the Department of
Education going after it in 1974 it had
to sue the Department of Education now
see that's a great sounding phone
we had to sue the Department of
Education before it was in health
education and welfare before a
functionary appointed by the Department
of Health Education and Welfare taking
his salary enjoying his tenure from the
same administration that had come
against us and you know what they did
they did exactly the kind of thing the
King dud used to do to the colonists
they were located right here in the
center of the universe in Washington the
District of Columbia and we were located
in Hillsdale Michigan so of course they
held the hearings in Denver Colorado and
the reason is hard to get farther away
without going to California and I guess
the guys wanted it might have been the
winner maybe they wanted to ski and see
they're spending the taxpayers money and
we're spending our own and then we had
to sue and fight with those guys for
years and spend our money to get a
ruling from one of their functionaries
and you know didn't work out very well
wonder of wonders
you know why is 80 abandoned its attempt
to take over whatever it is t-mobile I
don't even know if I want them to do
that I don't even care what I care about
is somebody has decided that many
billion dollar thing and who is that
somebody and where is the separation of
powers and where are the checks and
balances and doesn't that tell us
something we could do now couldn't we
take those three things limited
government surely the government ought
to be less than half of the economy and
representation surely this fourth branch
of government should become
representative and separation of powers
surely all of these rules that they make
and enforce the making and the execution
and the enforcement should not all be in
the same hand
and by the way if we could do those
things we would have our safety back we
wouldn't quite have our Constitution
back but we would have our safety back
and then we could work on the
Constitution and then we would be in
following the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution
together and I'll tell you finally what
the sanction is for those things come to
find out when James Madison is
explaining in the most beautiful places
where explains why the Constitution is
written the way it is in one place he
says it is our reason that should be
placed in control of the government our
passions must be controlled by it you
know the best thing I'm doing this term
I'm teaching 17 students Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics we finished yesterday
it's just about the most fun people can
have without getting arrested and it was
it was sublime fun to do with these
young people see and they want to be
good they want to learn to have a good
character and the summation of that book
could not be better made than saying
that it is the reason of man that must
be placed in control of his passions and
Madison knew that and he wrote the
Constitution to be a reflection of that
and then in another place about the
reason why the government and by the way
that means that we - every one of us
we're all human we can't just do
whatever we want we can't be given the
power just to do that but then what
about the government and its claims that
it can be trusted with any power
whatsoever and it can do today is the
day when the ocean ceased rising and the
planet began to heal but that's a
strange you ever read the first
paragraph of Bill Clinton's first
inaugural address we meet here in the
Bleak of winter but by what we say and
the faces we show the world we can force
the spring
nature itself is asked to bend isn't it
not the laws of nature and of nature's
God Medicine says about nature that the
reason the constitution must be
organized the way it must be is because
we require to be governed because we are
not angels if men were angels no
government would be needed but if angels
were to govern men neither internal nor
external controls on the government
would be necessary I said that the
Declaration of Independence begins in
heaven doesn't that prove that the
Constitution the United States ends
there and doesn't that prove that in the
end and finally they are the same
document and we're going to get them
back or we're going to lose our freedom
and we're gonna live like barbarians but
we're not gonna let that happen
[Applause]
yes sir dr. Arnn thank you so much for a
lovely Christmas present
you're a lecturer and you're thinking
you alluded to but maybe you would
expand a bit on the problems of our
representatives passing laws to which
the bureaucracy then writes seven or
eight hundred regulations to carry them
out well I am happy not to have ever
witnessed this process but I read about
it the Obamacare bill in the dodd-frank
financial regulation bill I think
they're both two thousand pages long we
only have the evidence of a few
explorers who claim active actually to
have read either of those acts so let's
say they're 2,000 pages long well the
agencies there they're really only
blueprint documents and so the agencies
are busy in fact right now making the
rules and that's a vast log rolling
process right everybody shows up now
we're making rules and what what do
industries do while that's going on they
support and they trade their support in
exchange for a seat at the table and
then they make many many many more pages
than the original 2,000 pages of rules
and I'll tell you how that you know my
first a practical encounter of that was
I was hard at by Bill broad back at
Hillsdale College in 2000 and I hung in
green and stupid and I thought you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna read title
four of the Higher Education Act because
that's the thing that we're giving up
several million dollars a year not to
have to abide by I'd like to know what I
get it for the money for not having the
money and so I called our lawyer we I
don't think we still have him I hope not
but
for years and years we kept a lobbyist
in town whose job was to keep the
government from giving us any money it
cost 30 or 40 grand a year to make that
happen
and a good good person to and I called
him up and I said you know I want you to
send me title four of the Higher
Education Act if that is in fact the
part that we are escaping by not taking
all this dough and he said no use no use
in my sending it and I said why not and
he said well you won't be able to read
it you know he's like Morell back there
from Yale Law School right he thinks
thinks he's real smart and I said I said
well you know reasonably intelligent man
maybe I can't read it what are you a
lawyer and and he said no I said I can't
read it either
we keep a specialist to read it and
she's actually the only person I ever
met who can read it now Madison says in
the 73rd Federalist that if the laws are
so voluminous are changeable that you
can't read them then it doesn't matter
if they're made by the rod for right
process and you know that's a feature of
constitutional rule I'll mention it you
know one reason why Hillsdale College
you know there's a bunch of people here
who work at Hillsdale College and you
know I got no idea what they've been
doing today except probably they've been
doing really well because they're very
good people and because in Hillsdale
College we all know what we're about and
we and the reason is we keep it simple
you know I said at the beginning there
three things I had an accreditor say to
me one time I've never been anywhere in
30 years where everybody could tell me
what the mission statement was how did
you do that and I said I'm done she said
who did it and I said well we all did it
and she said how did you do it and I
said we run the college out of it it's
simple right that's constitutional rule
it disperses power and invites people to
cooperate
it's the reason it works it fits with
human nature whereas we're proving it
right now in America
you can't be rich enough to sustain a
process like this and I'll tell you one
more thing go read the North I'm sorry
go read the Northwest Ordinance to go
read the Homestead Act those are the two
greatest pieces of statute law I've ever
read one of them sets up the mechanism
by which the United States of America
will grow across the continent and it's
a unique document it's very beautiful
document and the Homestead Act gives
away 10% of the land air of the United
States two for free
to about two million people the
Homestead Act is about the length of the
Declaration of Independence about
thirteen hundred and fifty words words
not pages words giving away that much
land the Northwest Ordinance is under
4,000 words and and you know it sets up
governments it's very complex right but
they thought it should be simple and
that's a that's a key thing we should
learn the art of constitutional
legislation again we have lost that art
and so we can't imagine running anything
without somebody off somewhere heck and
gone away making a bunch of rules yeah
yes sir was the first american statesman
to sever the two documents
okay did you hear that
that's good question what wilson was
sort of against both of them and and
franklin roosevelt you've got go read
the Commonwealth address there's a you
know there's by the way we're about to
publish our Constitution reader for
anybody to buy I think it's in David
winds are gonna be available do you know
it's in January the month of January no
more delays we're slowest Christmas at
doing fundamental things but that's
because they're fundamental and if you
read it you'll find that more than half
of the documents in the Constitution
reader are written by people who are
enemies of the Constitution the United
States and two Federalists Confederates
such as that and progressives and so
Wilson's idea was it's all outmoded the
founding itself the declaration
independence he says is accountable to
an aid is written for an age accountable
to Newton but now we have Darwin right
so it's obsolete it's passe and the
Constitution is just as bad every bit as
bad because it constructs a government
the way you he writes the way we
construct an orrery you turn a crank and
the planets go around the Sun you know
little change where old people like make
and remember these things and and a
chain and then the moon goes around the
earth right that's an order II and he
says our governments like an Ori and it
won't work so we got to get rid of both
of them and what Roosevelt did I in in
my reading and the reading of many
friends of mine have been working on
this for a long time and I'll interrupt
myself just to say this remember there's
an incredible work of recovery that's
been going on for a long time and one of
its focal points is that Hillsdale
College and you know Claremont
California across the street of heritage
there a lot of places where good work is
being done to try to figure out how did
it work what was the point of it what
about all these charges against it are
they true what Roosevelt did this
scholarship says and it's reflected in
this constant
you can read it in original source stuff
too by the way not what I say about it
Roosevelt figured out that the
Declaration of Independence is a kind of
magic it's very powerful and he sung its
music and he made it mean something
different and it won't work it's just
like Nancy Pelosi who follows him when
she speaks of the Dec Royce with great
reverence before the health care bill
but it won't support her reading of it
in in my argument and it's but it's good
she talks about it by the way because
now it's a thing there to be debated
let's have the debate so that's my point
my point is he condemned them both this
will be our last question yes sir
I know him well I'll get him later
thank you I'd like to follow up on this
gentleman's question here
authors like Gary will say that the link
that you and I believe in between the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution was not determined by the
founders that they didn't express that
themselves that it was actually Abraham
Lincoln that first made that sort of
connection and then from then on
constitutional scholars started talking
about that I'm wondering in your book
the founders Keys do you talk about that
explicit connection and do you provide
any kind of excerpts from the worst of
the founders in that area and perhaps
also in the in the Constitution
constitutional reader well I'll be
darned so I do
here's an example there's live you know
boring when somebody says well my book
does this and my book does that so
instead of telling you what the book
does I'll tell you a point the it
happens to be in the book but at the
point itself it's what's beautiful
during the weeks the three-week period
when the deck horse independence was
drafted and ratified or adopted the
state of Virginia was adopting the
Virginia Declaration of Rights and the
Virginia Constitution and George Mason
and James Madison and Thomas Jefferson
in absentia were on the committee and so
they're writing this these two documents
and they passed the two of them the same
body was heavy overlap with the
Continental Congress that was drafting
and ratifying the Declaration and the
two documents by the way are very
remarkable documents because both of
them contain elements of both the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution they both contain some
charges against the king and they both
contain Universal statements of how
government has to be organized to be
safe and by the way James Madison of
later fame was on the committee that
wrote it and the point is the Virginia
Constitution is not nearly as good as
the Constitution United States in just
exactly the way that a first effort is
not as good as the real McCoy and
Madison himself never of course
disavowed and Jefferson intervened in
the Virginia convention only to make the
separation of powers stronger he kept
writing a letter saying you can't have
it this you can't have it this close you
got to have you got to have these
devices also he was for a broader
suffrage than they the very broad
suffrage that they adopted so the point
is you just have to ignore things like
that because I'm saying not only are
these two documents the Declaration of
Rights and the Constitution being
written as the same time as the
Declaration of Independence and they're
like the Const
but they're also just like each other
and they overlap extensively so where
does that come from because you know
Gary Wells does say that about Abraham
Lincoln but you know who never says that
Abraham Lincoln never says that in
others he doesn't say ha I'm the one
that figured out
he says that's how it was I'm come to
find out go look I can't find anyway now
Gordon wood is a very great historian
was it mistake or to write but he he
what he thinks and see there is
something that's added in the
Constitutional Convention that's really
great
I mean it's because what's your life
like I'll tell you what mine's like I
first read the Nicomachean ethics of
Aristotle in 1974 and I'm no you know
they're people who know more about it
than I do but I love it very much and
I've been reading it all that time and I
know a lot about it now and I've just
taught it for the third time and you
know we actually had the class and I had
two extra classes we actually had
scheduled for extra classes but we
couldn't fit them in and since in my way
of teaching because I have to travel so
much every class is a week we went to
class for two extra weeks and we
regretted one time we had class of seven
o'clock in the morning over breakfast
and we regretted we didn't have more
time now my point is I'm better at that
then I was that's how my life works I
bet yours works that way too
I'll bet James Madison's worked that way
too
and so it's very possible that the truth
is what he said it was and that is if
the Constitution is different in some
ways and it is then then the Virginia
Constitution
maybe because he'd been thinking for 11
years and he'd gathered some experience
because he says it's the same thing in
principle and he says
twice in the Federalist Papers that the
purpose of the Constitution is to secure
a Republican form of government and our
individual rights and in the saying of
that he quotes the Declaration of
Independence and you know he and Thomas
Jefferson had one of the closest
political friendships in all of human
history so come to find out there's a
fact or two on the point and and I don't
know of the facts against the point
thank you
[Applause]